[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le mercredi
28 septembre merci de nous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de 7,8 le
journal on commence tout de suite avec
les titres 1
la maison de l'étudiant a été inauguré
ce matin pour l'occasion valérie
pécresse la présidente de la région ile
de france a fait le déplacement nous
vous ferons visiter ce nouvel endroit
dédié aux préoccupations des étudiants
et mauvaise nouvelle pour les yvelinois
les impôts augmentent fortement dans
notre département pourquoi les
explications à suivre et enfin un
concours pour des chefs opérant dans les
maisons de retraite cela s'est déroulé à
plaisir dans la maison le l'autre alors
qui a réalisé le meilleur dessert c'est
ce que nous verrons et catherine pégard
a été reconduite pour trois ans à la
tête de l'établissement public du
château de versailles ancien journaliste
et ex conseillère de nicolas sarkozy
elle est âgée de 62 ans et elle avait
été nommé en août 2011 à la tête de ce
site le parc le musée et le château de
versailles ont reçu 7 4 millions de
personnes en 2015 une fréquentation en
baisse de 14% depuis le début de l'année
un recul est attribué aux menaces
terroristes
et martha panne c'est le nom de la
nouvelle maison de l'étudiant de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines un hommage à la sculptrice
hongroise habitante de saint rémy les
chevreuse le bâtiment qui a ouvert ses
portes il ya déjà plusieurs mois a été
inauguré officiellement ce matin en
présence notamment de valérie pécresse
la présidente de la région ile de france
je vous propose de regarder ce reportage
signé nicolas kirillovitch
plus de 1700 m² une salle de sport une
salle de spectacle un espace
informatique la nouvelle maison de
l'étudiant de l'université versailles
saint quentin réunis sur un même lieu
l'ensemble des services dédiés aux
étudiants objectif leur simplifier la
vie il ya le service logement le service
d aide à l'handicap pour les étudiants
en situation de handicap et donc il faut
voir cette maison comme vraiment un lieu
où tous les services de la vie
universitaire pour les étudiants sont
regroupés ce qui nous permet nous un
meilleur affichage et une meilleure
intégration de nos étudiants dès qu'ils
s'inscrivent en tout l'ensemble des
services s'étale sur trois niveaux et
peuvent abriter notamment les 32
associations étudiantes de l'ue vs q
reste désormais aux dix-huit mille
concernés à faire vivre les lieux tout
au long de l'année bien sûr elle existe
elle est là et on est très content il
faut que les étudiants s'y investissent
créent des événements dans cette maison
de l'étudiant face des demandes de
matériel pour équiper la salle de
théâtre en fonction de leurs besoins une
phase des demandes concernant aussi la
cafétéria en fonction de seconde qui
veulent en bref c'est plus maintenant de
l'accessoire au quotidien que vraiment
les fondements les fondements sont là et
on est très content d avoir dévoilé
également le nom du bâtiment martha
panne référence et une sculptrice
hongroise connu du territoire en
cherchant et bien évidemment ça m'est
apparu assez rapidement une évidence que
ça pourrait être martha panne qui a donc
une sculpture dans les sources de la
bièvre qui dans les années 80-90 a été
c'était vraiment une artiste spécialisé
dans l'art urbain et qui a conseillé
les ministres de la culture pour la
construction d'oeuvre au sein des villes
coût de la maison de l'étudiant martha
panne plus de 8 millions d'euros financé
entièrement par la région ile de france
est une mauvaise nouvelle à présent pour
les propriétaires yvelinois vous l'avez
peut-être vous même constater les impôts
locaux ont fortement augmenté cette
année avec une hausse de la taxe
foncière de 66 % un record en france
mais aussi en ile de france les
explications avec haussmann vendeurs d
et nicolas kirillovitch
le chiffre est impressionnant plus 66%
aucun département français ne fait mieux
la hausse de la taxe foncière dans les
yvelines bat des records cette année de
cette vague l'eau 58 % en 2015 à 12,58 %
en 2016 soit une hausse en moyenne par
contribuable 225 euros et forcément la
nouvelle passe mal auprès des intéressés
toujours des hausses que ceux pour les
impôts pour tout augmente
malheureusement le pouvoir d'achat lui
n'augmente pas et voilà ça fait beaucoup
et
la marque je pense que à l'heure
actuelle ça fait mal au porte-monnaie
pour tous les français doivent peut-être
plus plus encore pour les yvelinois
matraquage tout simplement 66% c'est du
matraquage je peux comprendre qu'ils
aient des charges mais faut pas exagérer
quoi mise en cause le département charge
de l'impôt se défend évoque notamment
une hausse des dépenses sociales type
rsa mais accus surtout l'état et la
baisse des dotations une baisse qui
atteint cette année 38 millions d'euros
pour le département des yvelines même
mes collègues dans les autres
départements ne croyait pas que l'état
vous avez repris 90% de sa dotation tous
me disent c'est impossible puisque dans
les autres départements de l'ain a pris
30 aux cornes pour ça il ya les hybrides
ont été particulièrement puni pour une
raison très simple elles dépensent peu
elles sont économes des deniers publics
et elles ont une fiscalité faible et
quasiment pas de tête pour le
gouvernement actuel ça s'appelle de la
mauvaise gestion on ils le feront ceux
d'autres départements ont connu
également une hausse importante de leur
taxe foncière en 2016 c'est le cas par
exemple du voisin essonniens + 29 % pour
un taux d'imposition cette fois-ci de
16,37 % et prenant à présent la
direction de plaisir suite à de nombreux
sinistres ont février dernier mais aussi
en juin avec elle les intempéries les
terrains des peupliers sont
inutilisables un problème pour les
associations sportives les écoles de la
ville qui les utiliser pour y remédier
deux grands chantiers sont à venir pour
renforcer le terrain et le rendre à
nouveau praticable praticable par dont
les explications avec et michael enzi
trois semaines d'arrêt
suite à une rupture de canalisation mois
de février aux intempéries du mois de
juin les terrains des peupliers ne sont
plus que l'ombre d'eux mêmes ce qui pose
problème à de nombreuses associations et
écoles ça pénalise nos associations
sportives notamment
le foot
c'est puis les scolaires parce que
toutes nos installations sont occupés la
journée par les scolaires ça soit
collèges lycées les écoles élémentaires
et bien sûr le soir le relais est pris
par les associations sportives et pour
réhabiliter les terrains des peupliers
la mairie a prévu deux grands chantiers
une première phase c'est la
stabilisation de ses terrains et puis
l'amélioration de tout le réseau
hydraulique
au tour donc avec la création large y
semant des bassins de rétention d'eau
qui existent et la création d'un
deuxième bassin
le drainage qui doit se faire aussi en
aval de ce ces bassins et puis la
deuxième phase dans l'ours à cette
première phase va se terminer au mois de
décembre et la deuxième phase
interviendra à partir du mois de juin et
la cie la réhabilitation vraiment la
reconstruction des terrains ces deux
grands chantiers ont pour but de
renforcer le système hydraulique pour
résister à l'avenir aux intempéries les
terrains des peupliers seront de nouveau
utilisable avant la rentrée de septembre
et nous allons vous parler d'un concours
de cuisine un peu différent des autres
hier au sein de la maison lenôtre après
la plaisir a eu lieu la finale d'un
concours organisé par une entreprise
française de gestion d'établissements
pour personnes âgées ce sont donc des
bidons de chefs cuisiniers et de
personnel de ces établissements qui se
sont affrontés en pâtisserie sous l'oeil
attentif du chef étoilé frédéric anton
regard des
coups de feu en cuisine ces chefs ont
trois heures pour réaliser un dessert au
sein de l'école lenôtre il participe à
un concours de pâtisserie sous l'oeil
attentif du chef étoilé frédéric antoun
[Applaudissements]
ils sont très organisés très propre et
puis on voit qu'ils qu'ils emploient des
techniques même au delà de certains
professionnels donc ça c'est beau à voir
parmi ces cuisiniers des directeurs
d'établissement des infirmières vous
corps d'huguette soignante chacun forme
un binôme avec un chef du groupe korian
leur point commun ils travaillent tous
dans cette entreprise de gestion
d'établissements pour personnes âgées à
l'origine de cette initiative
ce concours c'était vraiment ali
l'origine c'était de mettre à l'honneur
le métier de chef de cuisine de
cuisinier dans un établissement de prise
en charge de la personne âgée l'école
lenôtre c'est ici le je dirais le coeur
le coeur du réacteur on est en
travaillent maintenant ensemble en
partenariat depuis plus d'un an et demi
et c'est le lieu de l'excellence les
cuisiniers du groupe korian servent près
de soixante mille repas par jour
participer à ce concours c'est une
formation en plus et un nouveau
challenge comme pour david ce chef
bourguignon a élaboré son dessert avec
marie-hélène la directrice de son
établissement et toi sans cela la
démarche est engagée depuis déjà
quelques temps avec la dérision en
hébergement d'avoir une amélioration de
la qualité au niveau de la restauration
donc d'accord
apporter justement c'est ce petit
puisque lors d'un concours dans les deux
locaux donnent sur le nôtre percement un
puce les gagnantes du concours sont de
niçoises respectivement cuisinière et
psychologues elles auront la chance de
suivre une formation à l'école lenôtre
leur dessert sera par la suite réalisé
et distribué dans les trois cent
soixante cinq établissements du groupe
provocateur mais aussi un philosophe ben
est un artiste résolument populaire où
est la vérité c'est la question qu'il
pose aux visiteurs de la maison elsa
triolet aragon où il expose jusqu'au 27
novembre l'artiste né suisse réside
aujourd'hui à nice ils étaient présents
lors du vernissage
nous l'avons rencontrée wilfried est
réussi et nicolas kirillovitch
[Musique]
des réflexions des interrogations depuis
les années 60 ben pose sur ses toiles
ses humeurs ses états d'âme ici à la
maison triolet aragon il part à la
recherche de la vérité où est passée la
vérité c'est le nom donné à cette
exposition présentée jusqu'au 27
novembre moi j'ai aimé l'idée d'exposer
déchets à elsa triolet aragon parce que
je sais pas une connotation
intellectuelle qui me servait à quelque
chose ou pas mais ça m'a plu et puis
j'ai vu les dépliants il ya eu mes amis
monory et compagnie qui ont exposé ici
donc je me suis dit c'est un beau lieu
mais il savait pas qu'il y aurait
tellement demandé je ne savais pas que
c'était si important que ça une
recherche sur la vérité mais aussi et
toujours cette introspection guise de
fil conducteur l'égoïsme la recherche du
succès ben assume et revendique ses
contradictions c'est un peu hamlet est
un peu un peu quelque chose à moi c'est
que un à dix candidats en compte que il
est toujours à la recherche de la gloire
et est à la recherche de lui même et à
loger c'est donc un moment donné
ils s'aiment pas beaucoup mais il peut
pas faire autrement donc quand elle avec
il ya du moment où on a des piles de
l'idée du mois qui ne pensent qu'au mois
plasticien ben est aussi un performeur
il aime interpellé son public et
n'hésite pas improvisé lors du
vernissage une conférence interactive
sur son travail il ya des passages dans
laquelle les gens viennent paneuropéenne
de champagne hawks et ben oui c'est beau
magnifique c'est beau c'est cela et en
fin de compte c'est je peux faire
une exposition dans lequel on est beau
contre j'aime j'attaque soutien des
boucs qui est du doute
égocentrique mais qui aime être bousculé
dans ses certitudes ben est un artiste
provocateur et pour saisir les
subtilités de son oeuvre le musée
maillol à paris lui consacre en marge de
cette exposition une rétrospective
complète
et pour finir un mot de sport le plus
grand tournoi de golf amateur au monde
marque son étape française c'est l'une
des principales compétitions de golf
amateur au monde et celle ci aura lieu
au golf national de guyancourt le but
est de créer des liens entre les
différents clients de la turkish
airlines est aussi de rendre le sport
accessible à tous et en donner une
nouvelle image écoutez
secte vous savez dans l'aviation nous
avons une clientèle très variée
donc si nous voulons fidéliser le
maximum de clients nous devons les
attirer avec plusieurs activités et le
golf permet d'avoir des clients de tous
horizons
aujourd'hui nous avons 60 joueurs venant
de professions différentes
[Musique]
ce qui donne l'opportunité de créer des
vip
l'événement est ouvert et gratuit à tous
sous invitation et inscriptions sur les
sites internet
www.gva.ch richard line.com c'est la fin
de cette édition je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivis d'une édition un peu
particulière pour moi car c'est la
dernière fois que je présente le journal
sur tv fil 78 alors je tenais à vous
dire que j'avais été ravis de vous
parler de votre actualité locale presque
chaque soir pendant pendant un an ce fut
un plaisir également chaque jour de
recevoir en plateau des invités qui ont
accepté de se déplacer et qui vont
essayer de vous parler au mieux de ce
qui les animait je tenais également à
remercier la rédaction de tv fil 78
l'équipe de montage les monteurs qui
sont mal qui nous aident toute la
journée qu'ils montrent les sujets qui
font que ce journal existe et merci
aussi service d'infographie aux
webmasters à l'assistante de rédaction
également et aussi j'ai déjà dit à tous
les invités cru que c'était de venir se
déplacer en plateau avec vous merci
aussi à vous de m'avoir suivi d excuser
moi parfois pour mes petits dérapages et
parfois les petits savona j'espère que
comme ce rendez vous quotidien vous a
plu moi vraiment ça m'a beaucoup plu
j'étais ravi voilà de le faire avec vous
pendant un an le jt continue sur tf1
soit 118 je vous laisse entre de bonnes
mains et je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée au revoir
[Musique]